hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
and welcome back to my channel in this
video I'm going to show you uh some of
the tools talk about value areas in the
orderflow and how you could use them in
your trading and you know we're living
in some pretty volatile times you know
every other day it's a trade tariffs on
tariffs off or um something else going
on
economically um you know a lot of data
comes out fast and furious there's a lot
of talk about what the ped's going to do
or not going to do um crypto's crashing
or you know all all sorts of stuff and
you know it spills over into these
markets into the Futures markets you
know like the equities um that causes a
lot of volatility and you know people
always ask me you know how how can you
trade these markets with that have all
that volatility well one it says uh you
know pick a different Market but you
know if you're insistent on trading um
you know Equity indices during these
these volatile times um I'm going to
show you a tool that you know could help
you in your trading and and just show
you uh you know what what I'm referring
to really quick you know you see you
know this is just a simple one minute
chart in the snps and today um you know
since the the cash opened you know we
made a low rallied back up not to our
Highs but uh you know a nice it doesn't
look like much but this is a move from
56 all the way up to um you know above
5600 that's a 50 point move then from
this uh cash high from you know 5603
down to you know we're trading down at
at 40 right now so you know it's 50
point move up 60 point move down like it
or not there's just uh a lot of movement
in this market which can stress out a
lot of Traders and I want to show you a
a tool that we've developed to to help
Traders understand um what's going on in
the markets now you know if you're
enjoying my content be sure to subscribe
to the channel and hit that notification
Bell so whenever I post a new video uh
you'll be notified of it all all right
so um the the tool that I'm talking
about is the value area tool now I'm not
going to make this um video A whole
discussion on you know why you should
use value areas why or why not um you
know value areas is is a market profile
um concept you know it's where 70% of
the volume uh appears and you know
normally Traders their Market profile
Traders will look at the profile in the
value area for the day you know but they
also combine periods right sometimes
they look at the profile for a week um
what we're doing with order flow is
we're looking at it on a much smaller
scale we're looking at it on a bar by
bar basis okay so what you want to do is
you go down here you enable uh value
area right so you just tick this button
that says value area and hit uh apply
okay so it's going to draw the value
area in the bars right which is the the
area within the
bar where 70% of the V the volume traded
people will say well you know hey you
know isn't that you know very small very
granular well yeah it is and and you
know if I'm trading on a very shortterm
basis you know I want to know where the
value is you know where are we trading
at Value away from value um you know are
we going sideways Etc and there's you
know things that you can take away
from looking at the uh value areas let
me just make this crosshairs a little
bit bigger here so it's a little easier
to see where my cursor
is make that three here okay all righty
so you know one of the ways that you're
going to look at Value is you know how
you know is it going sideways because
you know sometimes you see a lot of bars
where value areas are overlapping that's
a sign of sideways markets um but
there's going to be times where the
market starts moving away from value
okay so you know similar to point of
control right where every bar has a
value are because you know every bar is
going to have value volume that traded
point control is the is the singular
price level in the bar where the most
volume traded whereas the value area is
the area in the bar where the most
volumea or 70% of the volume traded now
you know depending on how volume is
distributed throughout the bar it's
going to vary on where it comes in
sometimes it's going to come in you know
sort of towards the middle of the bar
other times it's going to come out
towards the bottom of the bar other
times it's going to be um you know you
know up here near the top of a bar Etc
and through our analysis over the years
we we found
that there are certain times what we
call absorption taking place in the
value area itself okay which is
important to us as a Trader because if
we can identify these areas right these
value areas where absorption is taking
place they could signal great trading
opportunities okay so what we've done is
we we've taken that analysis and we've
put it into the
orderflow trader software okay so what
you're going to do to use it is you're
going to go scroll down to the value
areas and you're going to click here
value area absorption
now bear in mind right there's colors
involved here so a regular bullish value
area is going to be green color right if
the bar is green value area is going to
be green if it's a red bar the value
area is going to be colored red however
with absorption we're trying to make it
a little bit you know different so it
stands out a bit more and so we've made
the bullish value area absorption dark
blue and again you know I'm trying I was
trying to find a good color scheme to
use for the bearish one I I chose deep
pink but again you could change it to
whatever color you know if you don't
like pink you know um say you might get
confused or something you know you can
change it to I don't know purple or
whatever so see I see I got dark blue
blue for bullish value absorption purple
now for bearish okay and then just click
apply now what are one other setting
here is the draw mode okay so the value
areas I just have drawing in the
individual bar now the value area
absorption I have being drawn until
tested and what that means is once you
have a bullish value area absorption
appearing and the next bar doesn't trade
back into that value
area then that value area is going to be
extended out into the future until the
market comes back to that level just as
the bearish value area absorption it's
going to draw out starting at the bar as
long as the next bar doesn't trade back
into it so I'll show you what I mean and
that's important because now you know
what you're doing is you're
identifying when you have
absorption for bullish signal you know
technically would be distribution for
bearish signals and then you see the
market moving away from that okay
because if you have a sign of absorption
taking place and the market is just
staying inside that absorption well it
could possibly be more absorption right
same thing for distribution um really
what you want to be looking for are
those areas where the market is moving
away from that absorption okay and you
can see right here right so again
regular valuar are green for bullish
ones red for bearish
but the absorption that's taking place
in the value area is going to be colored
blue or in this case the purple color
okay and again you know what you're
looking for is not just that the bar has
a blue value area or a purple value area
what you want to see is the market
starting to move away from it okay so
you can see right here right bearish one
here right next bar does not trade back
into it so I know I had a sign of
distribution coming in here with what
was taking place in this
bar specifically inside the value area
and then the next bar is moving away
from that right and you see it's a nice
drop from you know whatever this is 55
55 56 all the way down into the 40s then
you got a bullish sign back up to that
level and then another bearish sign
right here and like I said just because
you have bullish value area absorption
if the next bar trades into that
that's not the signal that you're
looking for you're looking for it to be
trading away from it not coming back in
and testing that for it to be a valid
signal okay so again you know I don't
want to make this about value you know
there's a lot of good stuff on value
areas I honestly most orderflow Traders
are already familiar with value areas
but if if you're not you know go look up
uh some of the videos on YouTube you
know stle Dalton um nowadays there
there's a lot of other guys that that uh
do a lot of stuff with value areas but
the point is once you know that if
there's absorption taking place or
distribution up here or over here and
then the Market's moving away from it
right that creates
opportunity and that's what you want to
be looking for as a Trader and again you
know every bar is going to have a a
value just as every bar has a point of
control what you're looking for are
those instances where they actually mean
something okay because not every Bar's
value area is going to be meaning
something what you're looking for are
those ones that have deeper meaning okay
so um you know this
is e minis you know doesn't matter what
Market you're looking at um whether
you're looking at bonds or eurocurrency
or gold you know on a range based chart
on a tick based chart the same concept
applies okay people
sometimes get sort of Lost
in analyzing a market one market and
think you know it only works in this
market you know orderflow Works in all
markets okay and that that's the beauty
of orderflow because it's actually the
trading that's taking place in the
markets okay and you know markets are
fractal in a sense that you know things
happen on a bigger scale happen on a
smaller scale happen in different
markets all right because what orderflow
is is the market all right so that is
the value area absorption um and and how
to trade it and how to use it all right
everyone take care bye-bye